la rda avec les nouveautés du jour le
comité central convoque pour bientôt une
conférence du parti communiste et les
élections libres ne sont plus exclues il
faut dire que les dirigeants sont de
plus en plus inquiet face à l'hémorragie
qui continue encore 11000 est-allemand
ont quitté le pays et cela depuis 24
heures des élections libres c'est
justement ce que réclamer plusieurs
milliers de manifestants dans
différentes villes d'allemagne de l'est
hier soir dans la foulée ils ont sifflé
les noms des nouveaux membres du bureau
politique le plus important
effectivement pour l'actuel pouvoir
c'est l'exode et un certain nombre de
personnalités ont lancé hier un vibrant
appel aux éventuels candidats au départ
philippe rochot
toute la nuit les orateurs se sont
succédé à la tribune devant le comité
central du parti communiste
les électriciens des menuisiers des
membres du parti des étudiants ils
disaient leur joie ou leur peine après
l'élection d'un nouveau bureau politique
trop d'anciens reconnaissait certains
pas assez de changement disaient
d'autres mais les quelques 50 orateurs
qui se sont succédé à la tribune ont
demandé à tous les citoyens de rda de ne
pas partir c'est là que se trouve leur
patrie quel que soit leur régime un
appel vibrant de l'écrivain christa wolf
connu et reconnu par tous les milieux de
la littérature est-allemande et ouest
allemande auteur du livre le ciel
partagé sur la division de l'allemagne
restée au pays nous avons besoin de vous
appel signé par sept autres écrivains
qui n'ont pas la réputation d'être
fidèle au parti
gunter schabowski chef du parti pour la
région de berlin élu au bureau politique
parle d'élection prochaine sans en
définir vraiment le contour démocratique
une demande aux citoyens de rester au
pays même s'il paraît comprendre ce
qu'ils partent
le présidium de la chambre du peuple est
actuellement réuni est la principale
préoccupation des dirigeants
est-allemands et bien sûr de trouver le
moyen de faire rester les gens au pays
pour cela il dispose de deux arguments
chocs des élections libres et surtout
des réformes économiques
car au rythme où vont les choses en l'an
2000 il ne restera plus un seul citoyens
est-allemands sur le sol de la rda